Irma ist der erste atlantische hurrikan
der eine windgeschwindigkeit von 297 km
pro stunde
für die dauer von 37 stunden erreicht
hat schon seit tagen wüten dieser
stärksten aller zeiten durch die
karibik und hat jetzt die usa erreicht
6,3 millionen menschen müssen ihre
häuser in florida verlassen das ist die
größte evakuierung in den usa die es
je gab und firma sollen weitere
hurricanes folgen ist das jetzt schon
eine direkte auswirkung des klimawandels
und womit wer nahe zukunft rechnen
müssen jetzt im pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ja und irma ist nicht die einzige
unwetterkatastrophe in diesen tagen
zeitgleich sterben in indien menschen an
den folgen des staates monsuns
hunderttausende kämpfen dort ums
überleben extreme monsun regenfälle in
pakistan bangladesch und indien haben in
den letzten wochen tausende todesopfer
gefordert nach schätzungen sind bisher
2100 menschen starben 50 mal so viele
wie durch den hurrikan hw fachleute
bezeichnen den monsun als den
verheerendsten seit vielen jahren
lebensmittel werden knapp und
krankheiten breiten sich aus eine
absolute katastrophe ja und es gibt
jedes jahr natürlich diese monsunzeit
in südostasien von etwa juni bis
september und ja es gibt auch jedes jahr
hurricanes über dem atlantik doch die
aktuelle weltweite wetterlage scheint
doch besonders extrem sind dass also die
direkten auswirkungen des klimawandels
vor denen forschungsteams schon seit
langem warnen experten experten sagen
die extreme wetterlage diese extreme
wetterlage zurzeit ist kein zufall schon
jetzt steht fest der hurrikan immer wird
in die geschichtsbücher eingehen er ist
der stärkste erkennen der sich je in
der karibikregion über dem atlantik
gebildet hat kategorie 5 die höchste
stufe überhaupt irmer ist wirklich ein
monstersturm der wirbelsturm fegt mit
kurzen spitzengeschwindigkeiten sogar
von geschätzten 3 170 kilometern pro
stunde und hinterlässt chaos und
verwüstung ganze inseln stehen unter
wasser die menschen versuchen
verzweifelt sich selbst irgendwie in
sicherheit zu bringen 90 prozent der
gebäude auf der karibikinsel barbados
beispielsweise sind zerstört so
schätzt die regierung an den südlichen
küstenregion des amerikanischen
festland ist wie beispielsweise miami
sind millionen evakuiert worden es
herrscht seit tagen ausnahmezustand wie
groß die auswirkungen von irma wirklich
sein werden ist bisher noch nicht
abzuschätzen nur eins ist jetzt schon
klar es wird verheerend sowie den
bisherigen schlimmsten wirbelsturm er
überhaupt in der region andrew und
katrina die 1992 und 2005 für viele
opfer und gewaltige schäden in florida
bzw in der karibik entlang des golfs von
mexiko gesorgt hat von hurrikan harvey
der die südliche us ostküste
entlanggezogen war haben wir eines
gelernt nicht die windgeschwindigkeit
alleine sagt etwas über das
gefahrenpotenzial des tropensturms aus
durch die langsame rotation des sturmes
über das meer wird wasser aufgenommen
dass sich dann als regeln über das land
ergießt und alles überschwemmt
meteorologe andreas friedrich
wirbelsturm beauftragter des deutschen
wetterdienstes sagt auch immer ein hohes
niederschlags potenzial nach was dann in
regionen mit hohem gebirge zu
schlammlawinen und erdrutschen führen
könnte
als wären die starken sturmböen noch
nicht genug und das verheerende an der
ganzen situation nach irma werden
weitere heftige hurricanes erwartet wir
sind gerade mitten in der hurrikansaison
die menschen in den betroffenen gebieten
also können alles andere als aufatmend
fest stehen beide ereignisse monsun und
hurricane haben erst einmal nichts
miteinander zu tun es sind zwei
unabhängige extreme wetterereignisse
und doch haben sie eines gemeinsam
letztendlich sind sie auf wärmeres mehr
wasser zurückzuführen die temperaturen
im golf von mexiko beispielsweise lange
in letzter zeit bei 30 grad celsius und
das ist weit über dem langjährigen
mittel und da sind sich alle expertinnen
und experten einig das warme wasser
begünstigt die entstehung von
hurricanes extrem denn genauso wie die
tropischen wirbelstürme im pazifischen
und indischen ozean also taifune und
zyklone entstehen sie durch die
verdunstung von viel feuchtigkeit diese
steigt bei wassertemperaturen der oberen
50 meter von mehr als 26 5 grad celsius
langsam in die atmosphäre auf dabei
kondensiert die feuchtigkeit weder das
heißt sie geht von gasförmigen wieder
in den flüssigen zustand über so wird
die wärme energie wieder an die
luftmassen abgegeben und das treibt den
sturm an die energie der wirbelstürme
kommt also aus dem warmen meer
die ungewöhnliche erwärmung des
meerwassers spricht also sehr für die
klimawandel these durch das verbrennen
von gas öl und kohle steigt die
temperatur und liefert somit energie
für immer stärkere tropische stürme
und warmes meerwasser sorgt auch für
heftigen starkregen der monsun wird
stärker umso wärmer das wasser im
indischen ozean ist denn auch hier
steigt dann viel wasserdampf in die
atmosphäre auf und genau das ist der
zusammenhang bei der ereignisse mit der
globalen erwärmung wissenschaftsteam
sagen zwar dass kein hurrikan oder kein
extremer monsunregen
auf den klimawandel zurückzuführen ist
im klartext der klimawandel ist nicht
der direkte verursacher dieser stürme
und des regens doch eher verschlimmert
ihre intensität und somit auch ihre
verheerenden folgen viele klima
forschungsteams und auch der
weltklimarat den also davon aus dass es
in zukunft häufiger zu solchen
todbringenden monster stimmen also
häufiger wirbelstürmen der höchsten
kategorien wie immer kommen wird manche
expertinnen und experten sind noch
pessimistischer und also kam noch eine
schlechtere vorhersage und befürchten
durch den anstieg der globalen
durchschnittstemperatur zudem dass auch
die anzahl solcher extremen wetterlagen
steigt die klimaforschung selbst tut
sich schwer damit langfristige prognosen
abzugeben und vor allem wetter prognosen
abzugeben wie bei krebs also bei der
krankheit ist das ein ereignis nur
selten ganz konkret der ursache zu
zuordnen aber wie wir bei krebs wissen
dass zum beispiel asbest absolut
gefährlich und tödlich ist wissen wir
beim klimawandel dass er extreme
wetterereignisse extremer macht für das
ereignis sind die zusammenhänge aber
viel zu komplex so auch hier einige
expertinnen und experten aus dem bereich
sehen zwar auch dass die meere durch den
klimawandel wärmer werden
mit einer erwärmung der erde würden
aber auch mehr schwinde erwartet die die
bildung von wirbelstürmen verhindern
könnten
demnach könnten steigende temperaturen
also tatsächlich die zahl der hurrikane
vermindern quasi als hurrikan bremse
fungieren sie stützen sich dabei auf
simulationen die voraussagen dass solche
scheer winde im westatlantik zukünftig
vermehrt auftreten werden sie entstehen
durch unterschiedliche geschwindigkeiten
oder richtungen von winden die sich in
unterschiedlichen höhen befinden diese
hindern den simulationen zufolge den
hurrikan bei seiner entstehung oder
schwächen ihn ab wenn er sich bereits
gebildet hat doch auch diese vermutung
stellt keinesfalls den
wissenschaftlichen konsens über die
realität des klimawandels in frage
betonen auch die beteiligten forscher
und forscherinnen selbst zudem weiß man
auch nicht ob die änderung bei den
verbänden die hurricane fördernde
wirkung der ansteigenden meerwasser temp
natur aufhält nicht zu vergessen auch
eine zunahme der share winde wäre eine
folge der globalen erwärmung und damit
menschen gemacht zudem wird uns wohl
nichts anderes übrig bleiben als uns an
extreme wetterlagen anzupassen auch hier
in europa nahm er inzwischen auch einige
mega stürme und extremwetterlagen
erlebt heißt sichere häuser bauen
evakuierungsmaßnahmen optimieren und
auch warnsysteme ausbauen traurig aber
wahr
an dieser sache in regionen um den
pazifik und den indischen ozean ist an
solche maßnahmen im traum nicht zu
denken denn die infrastruktur ist dort
nicht mit der europäischen oder
amerikanischen zu vergleichen es gibt
andere drängende und existenzielle
probleme für die menschen die jeden tag
um ihr überleben kämpfen die menschen
auf dem inselstaat haiti zum beispiel
sie noch vom letzten hurrikan messe im
jahr 2016 und auch vom bürgerkrieg
geschwächt sind sie leben wenn
überhaupt in hütten die anders als
steinhäuser wirklich gar keinen schutz
bieten kein geld also um die kette aus
vorhersagen warnungen und evakuierung zu
optimieren
extreme wetterlagen führen in diesen
regionen schon deswegen regelmäßig zu
deutlich mehr opfern und wohin soll
bewohner einer insel flüchten an vielen
orten dieser welt gibt es also gar keine
möglichkeit sich vor solchen
katastrophen in sicherheit zu bringen
selbst wenn sie lange zuvor abzusehen
sind umso wichtiger also für uns für
die industrienationen selbst aktiv zu
werden und weiter konkret an den zielen
des pariser klimaschutzabkommens zu
arbeiten hier bei pixum halte ich euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video zum thema klimawandel und
auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann drücken wir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den genau
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter und
ich muss noch mal sagen mit was
interessiert mich das klima response
erfolge 05 das sprechen der
klimaforscher mojib latif und ich über
den klimawandel ein richtig gutes video
der bundeszentrale für politische
bildung auf keinen fall verpassen und
draufklicken ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran